less than one percent of cars on the
road in the uk
are currently completely electric that
means a radical transformation is needed
not only of the charging infrastructure
but also the manufacture of electric
vehicles
i think it is possible to transform the
infrastructure if government
and local authorities are totally
committed to it
but without that commitment then a
target of 10 years
time is incredibly optimistic
transport is the biggest emitting sector
in the uk
generating a third of the uk's carbon
emissions
the way we travel and the kind of energy
we use are some of the biggest
changes britain will see in the next
decade
in an attempt to tackle climate change
the 10-point plan includes ending the
sale of new petrol and diesel vehicles
by 2030 instead of 2040
hybrid vehicles will still be sold until
2035.
wind nuclear and hydrogen will be key
components of a green grid
with plans for a town heated entirely by
hydrogen
by the end of the decade and the
government wants the uk to be a leader
in green technology
in particular carbon capture and storage
which
sucks carbon out of the air the
government says it's investing 12
billion pounds in its climate strategy
but analysts have told sky news only
four billion of that is new money
labor says the announcement falls short
of what's required
but the independent committee on climate
change which advises the government how
to get to net zero
has welcomed the plan i'm just so
pleased to see the prime minister
make a statement like this it's um it's
a really a bold statement
of ambition and um it's great to see a
prime minister of of britain set out a
vision like this
what's missing i suppose is the the road
map to achieving it
is this enough for britain to meet its
target of being net zero by 2050
it's not enough alone but my goodness it
will progress the issues
the pressure is on boris johnson to show
leadership on climate change
this plan is a start but it's a long
road to net zero by 2050
lisa holland sky news